c'est un rituel quasi sacré le mois
d'août venu la France se met à l'arrêt
une dose de liberté après des mois de
confinement de couvre-feu et autres
restrictions sanitaire
les appels l'air du large retrouvé
qu'une ombre vient pas Cendrillon
l'horizon la situation sanitaire se
dégrade les taux de contamination encore
un un virus s'envole la 4e vague full le
littoral résultats une trentaine de
départements français impose de nouveau
le port du masque en plein air à
l'exception des plages et des grands
espaces verts
ici à Menton sur la Côte d'Azur mais
insouciance des vacances auquel on
s'accroche peut-être le message mais
visiblement pas passé là on vient de
Monaco Monaco c'est marqué partout
mettre le matin on avait le matin donc
les directives sont pas claires
pour une bonne partie de la population
locale
faut pas plus acceptable
donc les hôpitaux de la région de La
Provence et de la Côte d'Azur on décrit
tu es un plan blanc c'est-à-dire qu'on
est de retour à la possibilité de des
programmes et des interventions qui sont
jugés comme non urgence parce qu'on
manque de personnel avec un achalandage
des hôpitaux pour la covit qui a
augmenté une fois de plus de 56 % de
nouveaux patients qui sont de plus en
plus jeune et souvent non vacciné pour
l'instant c'est une dose ensuite une
deuxième dose ensuite ça fait trois dos
peut-être pour le plus proche et puis en
fait on va peut-être le faire une fois
tous les ans
en fait on n'en sais rien non plus de ce
vaccin
pour l'instant non je suis pas vacciné
j'attends qu'on me qu'on me oblige et on
verra si je le fais même obligé
pas sanitaire pour accéder à des lieux
publics la France force la main des
réfractaires comme Antoine si la
vaccination n'ai toujours pas
obligatoire sauf pour le personnel
soignant dès lundi Antoine pourrait bien
ne plus pouvoir travailler au contact du
public
il n'est toujours pas convaincu mais
d'autres se résigne on a complètement à
notre profil de l'individu c'est un
bidule à sont les invités du par rapport
aux directives
gouvernementale ministériel où il y a
entre guillemets je viens de vaccination
et là ce sont des gens qui sont
impatients sont des gens moins
respectueux
[Musique]
c'est de plein gré que Sophie vient se
faire vacciner elle n'en peux plus du
débat qui m'ennuie autour de la
vaccination même si tout le monde pense
des avis différent je me plie à ce qu'il
faut faire par solidarité comme en temps
de guerre point final
une sortie mère-fille pour Sophie et
Carla 14 ans qui ne s'entendent pas
nécessairement sur les motivations
derrière leur visite au centre de
vaccination moi je veux bien le faire
avec nous parce que ça peut me permettre
d'aller dans des magasins pour l'école
moi j'ai pas trop d'avis je préfère le
faire s'il faut le faire c'est tout un
petit geste conclu la mer pour enfin
passer à autre chose du moins c'est ce
qu'elle espère ici Marie-Eve Bédard
Radio-Canada